[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it is the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships talking about the real
thing I am your host Jade warshaw I am
joined by maybe my favorite co-host ever
Dr John deloney over here to my right
we're going to have a good time give us
a call the number is 88255 225 we'll
talk about your life we'll talk about
your money we'll talk about your mental
health and wellness but before we get
into that Dr John we were just in the
NYC we were in New York City this
morning Party in the USA we were
partying in the USA we were in New York
um for a media dinner we got to sit and
hang out with a whole bunch of cool
folks yesterday and then we did some
media this morning and then we got on a
plane and flew here just in time to save
America I'm like pinching myself
somebody has to good grief I'm like what
is happening I I went on social media
yesterday and I was like all right you
know come check out the TV we'll be on
Fox news with you know America's
Newsroom I was like wow that's crazy
then this morning I was like hey come
check out the TV we'll be on here with
Fox and Friends I was like wow that's
crazy our life is just really been cool
and it's all thanks to you guys uh
thanks for listening to the show thanks
for sharing the show thanks for tuning
in whenever we talk we couldn't do it
without you guys and without further Ado
we got to take it to the phone lines we
got Jessica in NYC we just came from
there Jessica what's going
on yeah hi well thanks for visiting us
it was fun um I bet um so I am my
husband and I are trying to start to
prepare for my retirement um in
approximately five years um I am a
teacher locally and I will be retiring
with a large pension approximately
$100,000 a year um but I also have an
opportunity to get a lump thumb um which
is quite significant how do you
determine what is the best course of
action whether to take the pension and I
know Dave usually says to take the lump
Thum but due to me being so young and
potentially um being able to collect for
an extended period of time and get
spousal benefits for my husband I just
want to know is there a calculator or a
formula that you use to um to pick yeah
you know I all I can tell you is what I
would do and I'll tell you the reason
why I would do it and then if you have
some information that kind of
contradicts that feel free to share it
um the reason I would take the lump sum
and in my case you being a little bit
younger is actually a good thing cuz I
would take the lump sum and then I would
get with a smart Vestor Pro and I'd
reinvest it and you are going to get a
better rate reinvesting it in good
growth stock mutual funds across the
four types that we teach you're going to
get a better rate of return than you
were ever getting with your pension um
because even the way we teach it we say
like hey we we suggest for people to
invest 15% of their income right but if
somebody calls in here and says hey
uh I've got a pension and I'm putting
you know 10% into it does that count as
10% we tell them no count it for like 5%
and we say that because of the rate the
rate of return that you're likely
getting on that pension and so in your
case if I were you you're going to walk
away with so much more money because if
you get with the right investor and in
the right funds you're going to have an
awesome rate of return I mean what are
you
50 uh I will be 50 this year so I have
um about five more school years after
this one oh yeah that's great and I mean
you're going to retire but I'm sure
you're going to go on to do other things
it's not like I'm going to work I'm a
worker I'm so there's no no doubt that
I'm not going to work but I am concerned
because my husband is not GNA have a
pension or a retirement we do have a
four or 3B but I am concerned to make
sure that I'm preparing for him and
leaving the Legacy for my kids 100% if
you take the lump sum how much is
it um it's estimated at
1.33 million girl I would do it right
now yep let me let me tell you two other
things let me tell you two other things
um the first one is you are never
guaranteed
tomorrow right and I wouldn't have a job
if everybody lived to to be 95 years old
right and before this I spent a lot of
time in homes in the middle of the night
hugging husbands because their wives
have passed away from and I have had
health issu issues I'm a cancer survivor
from 36 so so if you imagine your kids
and your husband you've got this
incredible pension that makes you're
getting paid six figures and then you
get sick and then something happens and
then they're out and he's 60 years old
with nothing versus you got this so I it
almost feels safer to me to know I've
got a million dollars in the bank that
is going to compound every seven years
if invested properly it's going to
double and so you're thinking man if I
live 21 more years right just to the
average um it'd be a little below
average then you would have three four
four million dollar right four and a
half I mean so you see what I'm saying
minus whatever yall withdrew so I'd pull
it out here's the second thing I would
tell you and I'm just telling you this
like if I was sitting across the table
from my
mom I personally I don't have any secret
info but I don't see a path forward for
all these pensions to pay out as they've
promised similar to Social Security
they've been so heavily leveraged and
borrowed against and bond it out I don't
trust the fact in 30 years they're going
to be paying what they are I just I just
I don't see a path forward especially
with their grown-ups in Congress acting
like children throwing crayons at each
other I just don't see it John you make
a good point and that's a good thing to
remember Jessica is a a pension can die
with you like and you mentioned wanting
to take care of your family so that's
one thing or if your company goes under
that also puts your pension down the
tubes if one day New York had we were
just there and everyone we talk talked
to talked about how New York hasn't come
back yet the real estate um you know all
those shuttered first floors of all
those buildings that used to be just
hopping if it would not surprise me if
New York has to um sit down with the
union and negotiate and it' be a bloody
battle and you know it would be but I
just don't I don't see a path forward 30
years from now now hopefully I'm wrong I
would do anything to be wrong um but man
I'd much rather have $1.1 million in my
checking account that's under my control
that I get to decide what happens to
down the road than to Hope New York
makes good choices
because they have don't have a great
track record so Jessica you're going to
take that money get with that smart
Vestor Pro you're going to invest it
across four types we teach this all the
time 25% into each category you got
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international that's what you
want to do that is the path forward do
you have any
questions well what if we wanted to take
some of that money and purchase some
real estate oh I would ask I'm going to
hustle anyway I would ask if you are in
baby step seven and if you are I would
say yes do that becomes part of your
your portfolio yeah at that time you
will be yes that's the way to do it
we're gonna relocate and get off of Long
Island which is ridiculous yes ma'am
that's the way to do it when you're in
baby step 7 you pay cash for real estate
and you become even wealthier than you
already are which is pretty dang
incredible I love calls like that John
it's awesome very cool and thank you for
being a teacher and I'm looking at the
statistics um jade and Jessica thank you
for not just quitting this year I know
that's right you're going to ride out
for five more years thank you those kids
in New York are lucky to have you yeah
and you're modeling for them what a hard
worker looks like and a thinker looks
like I'm so grateful that's awesome in
more ways than one I love how she's
wanting to take care of her family I
love when people really dial into um
their money not just for the now but for
the future because the the choices we
make can cost us hundreds of thousands
of dollars when it comes to investing
what we're looking at what we're not
looking at so I always admire when
people are smart enough and diligent
enough uh and intentional enough to call
in and really get the right advice for
their money hey and by the way this is
just an INE equals one experiment but my
parents both changed careers in their
50s and they are incredible into their
70s so your husband says he's not going
to have anything he could if he chose
right now to start doing something
different it's not too late this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
what's going on everybody you're
listening to the Ramsey show thank you
for listening I'm your host Jade warshaw
joined by John deloney give us a call
we'd be happy to take your call we'll
discuss whatever you want to as long as
it has something to do with your money
or your mental health John over here is
really the best guy to talk about mental
health and wellness tell them what you
do John I'm not the best there's some
really good ones out there but we'll
talk to you about your relationships
mental health whatever's going on in
your world your emotional health life
has gotten sideways for everybody and
it's a mess it's a mess I like the way
you talk about things though because for
me there's no like lingo like it's not
over my head it's like oh I can do that
like that's me he's talking to me so
that's one of the things I like about
the way you speak to the People John
including me I'm one of those people but
give us a call Tri 825 5225 and we'll
chop it up we got Ashley in Columbus
Ohio what's going on Ashley
Hi how are you both doing good how are
you I'm good I'm a little nervous so I
wrote down my question that's awesome um
just a slight just a slight background
I've had three surgeries in a year and a
half so the fact that John boney's on
here talking about mental health these
surgeries have definitely wait on me
mentally um because of that we slid back
into baby step two due to all of the
medical bills um that we accured with
that um we were making really great
Headway until earlier this month we
received a letter in the mail stating
that we had a $2,000 bill that was about
to go into collections um we had never
received notice of this bill prior um so
when we inquired more about it um it was
from 2021 to two years ago for physical
therapy from my first surgery um we got
negotiated down from the 2,000 to about
1300 okay um however we're having a
problem with the office giving us a
final bill in writing that that is our
going to be our final notice and I don't
want to be on the hook for $600 when I
can't get anything in writing and
honestly I just want these medical bills
gone for for my mental can you my mental
health and wellbeing have you driven
over
there um I have um and I've talked to a
supervisor and they said we'll give you
date that you know that it went over it
came down to a dispute from my prior
insurance and my prior employer um but
they're not give willing to give me
anything in writing other than the dates
and the most recent Bill we got was
1,800 so it came down a little bit but
I'm afraid again we're going to be on
the hook for all of that if we can't get
something in writing do you have
it I have a voicemail from them do you
have
$1800 um not really we've got our $1,000
emergency fund and slightly over that we
have about 12 and so we're working
pretty quickly to get all of that um you
said the bill was col you said the bill
was in collections right
no it was the final notice prior to
collection okay got it got it um let me
tell you what I would do and Jade tell
me if I'm
wrong I'll do just about anything for
peace in my home and I would probably um
as your husband as your neighbor as your
somebody that went to church with you as
as your as your sister I would go drive
Uber I would go babysit I'd go wash cars
I'd go do something and scr scrun up
this money and just pay the stupid Bill
and be done move on I it's so yeah and
that's what my husband I talked about as
well I it's just not worth my soul now
my friend George Campell would he would
he would get a tent and Via very bougie
nice tent because that's how he rolls
but he would go park it in front of the
hospital and he would or in front of the
PT place and he would sit there every
day until they finally so that's how he
rolls it's everybody's
different I personally if they did the
if they actually did the therapy and and
they did the work that they're claiming
that they did I would pay them the money
and be done with it I'd try to figure
out a way to make iten and here's the
other thing you know this as well as I
do one of the things that surgery the
mental health toll surgery takes is
there's that
scary sense that my body let me
down right there's something about me
that's not working right and then
there's that pervasive pain that hurts
all the time and they work you through
therapy to slowly take teeny tiny little
baby steps with that pain one of the
ways you regain trust in yourself is not
through standing in front of the
standing in front of the mirror and
manifesting it's a whole bunch of little
wins and my promise is if you and your
husband scr and scratch and Claw and get
1,800 bucks and just get this stupid
thing paid over paid out even though
it's going to cost you some time you're
going to miss some te- ball games you're
going to miss whatever you will stand a
little bit taller that's a path right
you'll have little step little step
little step boom y'all are done you're
out of our life
and then you'll say all right we did it
and then that will catapult you into
getting back to Baby Steps three and
four and
on okay yeah and that's that's kind of
was our second um kind of our fallback
like hey if we have no choice but to pay
the 1800 and we don't take the discount
then that's kind of the end of the the
story with that and we move on to the
next medical bill um and I agree with
what you said it you know I do feel like
my body has failed me since it's it's my
series it's that's how literally it's
exactly how I feel yeah M and one of the
best ways to get confidence back in your
body is to slowly begin to use it again
right both intellectually both working
really hard towards a towards a purpose
purposeful goal and doing physical
things right and it's just one of those
things that it you you feel like I'm
going to do this workout and tomorrow
I'm going to feel like a million bucks
and you don't you look in the mirror and
you kind of look the same it's little
bitty things that accumulate over time
and then suddenly something's going to
happen and you're going to be strong and
you're going to think oh wow I'm back
right it's awesome it just takes a bunch
of little steps over and over and over
and it's disciplined and it's annoying
and it's slow and it just happens and it
happens and you're all going to get
there and get it done I agree with that
wholeheartedly I'd pay it um I want you
to keep every piece of paperwork on this
I want you to keep this paper trail
especially if it's been inconsistent the
thing that's probably consistent is the
account number so they'll be a if
there's ever a discrepancy you'll be
able to see hey this account went from
2000 to
1,800 I paid it you know you'll always
be able to see that so always keep the
paperwork um especially if you are
dealing with a collections uh company
you definitely want to keep the
paperwork because those Jokers will come
back you know five six seven years later
talking about you didn't pay because you
made a settlement so always keep the
paperwork always in a file folder and do
not give them your checking account
number they're going to ask you for the
routing number so they can just um
direct withdraw it do not oh that's such
a good point don't don't don't send a
money order or have your bank wire it
but do not do not do not do not do not
give them your in information cuz you'll
have money leaking out of your account
for the rest of your life absolutely
yeah in this case definitely case all
right let's go to Manuel oh no let's go
to Nia she's in Orlando Florida what's
going on
Nia hi how you doing doing good how are
you good um so I just had a question uh
me and my husband just recently decided
uh to do the baby steps good um we uh um
our income just recently dropped because
he lost his job uh from like 880,000 to
50,000 um and we're already kind of like
living paycheck to
paycheck uh before that um so I wanted
to know if we should catch up on pass du
Bills first before uh saving an
emergency fund um or do we do the
emergency fund catch up on pass the
bills and then go into pay the
day so I want I do want you to do the
baby steps in the order I do want you to
get cuz here's the thing that ,000 if
you don't have that money you're going
to just go you're you're just going to
go more and more into debt and these
things are going to get more and more
past due but the key to making this work
because I don't want you to rob peter to
PayPal the key to making this work is
you've got to get that income back up um
he lost his job what's he doing in the
meantime um I have uh he's been kind of
working my business um I have a
bakery uh so are you paying him
we no money that we get so it started
off as a hobby like literally since we
needed extra money like I literally pop
a 10 out in my front yard in the house
and we just sell like cupcakes and stuff
to the neighborhood and whoever walks
past that's great for you Nia but right
now right now he's got to get a job that
pays I want him applying to like eight
jobs today and this is not the the beond
and all this is whatever's local this
Home Depot this Amazon this is whatever
he can get very quickly and start making
money very very quickly I'm going to
give you a couple of numbers so you see
how quickly this needs to happen the
average person gets their $1,000 saved
in 30 days that means you're selling
stuff that means you are working day and
night that means if cupcakes are making
you a little bit of money but you can
make more money doing instacart this
week in this month you're doing
instacart stop stop making kicks yeah
right now we're doing whatever is going
to make us the most money because not
only you need to get this thousand saved
you got to get caught up on your bills
and if it's rent we're getting caught up
on that one first if it's IRS we're
doing that one second then we're working
the debt snowball this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you for listening you're listening
to the ramsy show I'm Jade warshaw your
co-host with together with Dr John
deloney we're taking your calls all
afternoon longle 8825 5225 we're going
to do it up with the neighborly question
of the day today's question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is your one
place to find Reliable HVAC plumbing and
electrical providers near you Brands
like airserve Mr rder Mr Electric have
local professionals ready to help so
stop wasting time scrolling through
pages of results when you can just visit
neighbor.com today all right today's
question comes from Josh in Oregon Josh
writes I have no debt except for the
house and I have one credit card I've
never paid a penny of credit card
interest I treat it like a debit card
and pay it off every two to three days
next year my husband and I will acrw
$122,000 in medical bills due to having
a baby and my husband's medical
condition meaning our insanely High max
out of pocket my brother recently showed
me a few credit cards that have a
$11,000 bonus if you spend $4,000 in the
first three months since we have medical
bills and the cash to pay the bills he
suggested we get the credit card and use
it to pay our bills get the credit card
bonuses and immediately pay it off with
cash I know you're very against credit
cards but what is your opinion on this
go you called the wrong
show um yeah dude you called the wrong
show and I think that you should go with
your first instinct because you said
basically what does it say John she said
that she knows that we don't do credit
cards right I think she said that on
there except except hold on she's
special she's special and there's a
medical condition a baby and oh so she's
the exception to the rule correct oh
well in that case I'm still going to
have the same advice that we always have
no credit cards I would never ever ever
and this is being real I would never
ever ever suggest anybody to use a
credit card really ever the only time is
if for some reason they had like a maybe
if they were upside down on a car right
and their credit was shot and so they
couldn't go to a credit union you know
to get a little extra money to get out
of that upside down situation then maybe
I'd say okay do it on a credit card
right because you're going from a large
amount of debt to a much much smaller
amount of debt that is the only time you
would probably ever hear me say the
words here's how you could use a credit
card but in this situation you have
money you have money and $11,000 to
shuffle around debt in order to get
$11,000 in in in the time it took me to
answer this call you could find a more
productive way to make $1,000 doll I'm
just saying all right so here's my
two here's my two challenges with this I
actually get the math on it yeah the
math is fine you'll make your money cool
assuming everything goes according
everything goes perfectly right so I
know the stress of having a baby I know
the stress of having medical conditions
I don't know why anyone would elect to
add additional stress to that situation
I know to add more chaos like okay we
got to remember to pay this one off
because this one's got 1 th000 we're
going to roll this one over to the 4,000
and then we're going to spend this in
the three months we got to make sure we
get this bill back I don't know why
anyone would do that that's number one
okay but that's not enough for the math
the math folks I get that too it's
everything is worth it if you get that $
thousand doar or whatever here's my
beef these credit card companies are not
your
friend and so you are the rare and when
I say rare you're an albino unicorn okay
you don't exist in their world because
if people like you existed in Mass they
would close they'd go bankrupt they
wouldn't exist you pay it off every two
to three days
cool so that $1,000 bonus you're going
to get is going to be paid for with late
charges by that single mom who cannot
breathe in Southern Arizona whose
husband just left her and she can't see
the light of day somebody's paying that
thousand bucks and it sure as crap ain't
the credit card company and if it's not
you it's people that they've been
praying on that they are desperate
that's why I quit using them when it
came to Airline points I travel all over
the place it makes perfect sense for me
I'll just get reimbursed and I'll get
all these free miles and it occurred to
me wait a minute those flights aren't
free I love flying Southwest but they
are not my friend they're are great
service that I give money to so
somebody's paying for those flights and
we dug into it it's people who are in
deep terrifying financial trouble and
those are the folks that call the show
every day those are the folks that email
us and DM us every day and they're
literally dying inside that's a that's
I'm not going to let a single mom who
can't breathe pay for me to have $1,000
in bonus cash or a free flight to Dallas
I refuse to be a part of that game I
love that I I actually really like that
way of thinking about it um
and I think that probably if you were to
take a poll of all the various Ramsay
folks here we'd all have a different
reasoning for the credit cards and I
love that reason that's definitely
something to chew on um my reasoning is
slightly different but similar but
different my reasoning behind it I mean
we can get into math stuff and you know
debt and all of that but mine is and and
you can tell me what you think about
this John I don't like a company who a a
mass majority of their profit and
revenue is based on people defaulting
failing failing the customer has to fail
forom has to fail for them to make money
of course they get money on
transactional fees and all these other
things but the money that they acrew in
late fees and overbalance I'm like wait
a second cuz I can go there's plenty of
companies out there I can go to Jordan
brand and buy a pair of shoes and I
don't have to fail in any way in order
to get the service that's right like I
can go over to Publix use their you know
grocery store service or Instagram and
or instacart you know grocery shopping
app I don't have to fail in any way to
get value from their service anytime a
business's main profit source is the
failure of their customer thank
Blockbuster they didn't make money on
renting movies they made money on your
late fees you had to lose you have to
lose for them to win they will go away
yeah if you provide a service like an
incredible shoe that has value that
looks cool and we're just here to serve
you we want to give you fashion I'll
give you my money you give me fashion
right that's a fair
but if they fall apart or if when the
new Jordans came out if they suddenly
pushed a button like maybe one uh fruit
company that makes cell phones does and
they push the secret button and your
phone starts working not as well right
yes the big red button they only make
money when their customers fail yeah I
have a major problem with that and then
okay let's keep let's keep rolling this
out cuz we got time on this clock John
so there's that part let me tell you my
next part about credit cards they get
into your psyche and they have told us
for decades
you can't exist without us and so Brick
by Brick they've toorn down our
confidence to be able to handle money as
individuals because they've said hey
your paycheck's not enough you working
hard 40 hours a week is not enough you
need supplement you need extra you need
more you need to be able to keep up and
here's how you can do that we'll give
you this piece of plastic we'll loan you
our money at insane interest rates and
now there you go now you're good go play
and so now we talk to folks all the time
who call in and they're like Jade I'm
terrified I'm terrified to cut up my
credit card it has nothing to do with um
I want to get the points and the rewards
and this no I'm just scared that I won't
be able to manage my money without this
safety net that I've had in my life for
5 10 15 years that's crazy and I hate
that a company has had the ability to
destroy our confidence in that way to
just go oh yeah yeah if I mean if I make
$3,000 a month I just I can only spend
$3,000 a month like I can go into I have
the confidence to say I go into the
grocery store and I just only spend $200
I have the ability to tell myself no and
I have the ability to say oh if I say
this is the goal and this is the plan
yeah I'm confident that I can stick to
that but we've totally wiped that out of
our Consciousness and out of our
confidence and now we're like oh I don't
think I can say no like I don't think
that I can actually stick to this I
better keep that piece of plastic as my
fail safe so that's that's argument
number three you got another one I got I
got a number four let's go so they're
going to give you a $1,000 bonus if you
spend $4,000 in the first 3 months cool
what they are banking on is that you're
going to spend $4,000 in the first three
months they're going to give you a th000
bucks they'll get that money back oh
yeah they will get that money back and
here's how the research shows you spend
more money when you're swiping plastic
than when you're paying with cash or
even coming out of your debit card yes
and so you might pay this thing off
every two to three days but you are
expenses are higher percentage wise than
if you were just carrying cash around
that's right because it doesn't doesn't
matter you're going to pay it off later
so they're going to get their ,000 back
in transaction fees that you otherwise
wouldn't be spending they're going to
get their money back opt out of the game
don't play with Predators man do not
play the game we're not playing with you
guys when it comes to these credit cards
we are only going to tell you what we
know to be true this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian healthc Care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that was
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at CH ministries.org
[Music]
budget
you are listening to the Ramsay show I
am Jade warshaw this is John delone
we're with you all afternoon give us a
call 88255 225 we just came from New
York City uh where we do something
really cool there John um you know we
get the opportunity to go on different
people television shows news networks
podcasts and there's a lot of people
that go into making that happen so many
folks behind the scene producers and
Bookers and all these people and I think
Ramsey does something really cool by
hosting a dinner to just say thank you
to just appreciate all the people that
let us let us near them and let us on
their Airwaves and trust us and it was
really cool to see that um how much goes
into that and so in the spirit of that I
really just want to say thank you to
those listening now thank you guys so
much for listening to the podcasts the
YouTube channels everything I mean the
fact of the matter is John and I would
be unemployed if it were not for you and
so we're just super duper grateful um I
don't think we say it enough thank you
and let's um let's let's show show
people a little bit behind the curtain
um he would never do this on the air but
Dave's a Gruff guy on the air and he's
tells it like it is you know it's when
you see see Dave um in the the the lower
basement of a building and the way he
interacts with and tips the Bell hops in
the shadows that nobody will ever see
yeah and the way he said 10 years ago
man we're going on all these people's
shows and there's the the hosts in front
of the cameras M but there's all these
people behind the scenes making this
thing happen and their life is they're
up at 3:30 in the morning they're making
up all the all the shows making sure
everything's running gun doing far more
work than
way more work far more work than us and
Dave said we've been blasted beyond
measure I'm going to fly my whole team
up to New York and we're going to take
care of them for a night and so it's
just that there's a generosity that's
staggering behind closed doors um this
just pretty cool to be a part of it is
very cool but just want to take that
moment and kind of let you know what's
going on let us know that we thank you
guys for listening if you enjoy the show
it means so much to us that you even
have the grace in just to share it that
you click subscribe all of that means so
so much to us not only does it help us
but it helps somebody else uh they get
the message out they get the word they
get that that that message that's going
to change their money that's going to
change their mind that's going to change
their family it's so so so important
thank you and with that we're going to
go to man well in Houston Tas what's
going on hello guys thank you for having
me you're welcome thanks for calling in
what's going
on uh so I'm actually in a big mess um
so I have a backstory I'm a starter so
you guys understand okay uh about a year
ago I went through a really bad pH of
depression and well I made some dumb
mistakes that I'm now paying
for um I got myself into $70,000 of uh
debt I purchased things I I knew I
couldn't afford but I just didn't care
at the moment and well today I'm making
uh roughly about $20,000 a year maybe a
little less than than that I am working
on getting my uh CDO my commercial
driver's license so I can make more
money uh it's just this is really hard
to get right now but to break it down
for you I have about 19 or 18,000 in
credit cards and uh personal loans debt
okay I have uh bought a car uh it's a
very expensive car you guys are going to
be so angry on me how much it was
$50,000 I now own 46,000 on it and I
also about a motorcycle that I owe like
5,000 on it you owe 5,000 on the
motorcycle yeah okay um which do you
want to get first do you want to get
John's take or do you want to get Jade's
take you get to choose but you're gonna
get both uh either
one all right here's the deal man first
thing before you get going I need you
when this call is over to go look in the
mirror and look yourself dead in the eye
okay I need you to say the following I
screwed up but I'm not a screw
up the game changes right
now okay yeah I need you to repeat that
over and over and over I'm worth fixing
all this stuff okay the funny thing you
calling me and Jade 70,000 bucks doesn't
make either of us blink because we've
both had way way way more debt than that
okay and both of us have gone through
ups and downs so same team all right um
the $50,000 car that you owe 46 Grand on
that's sold by the end of next week
right
yeah and after I selling the car already
uh I just owe so much money on it and uh
they will only give me like
34,000 have any money to uh pay for the
upside down when you looked on if you
look on kellybluebook.com what's the car
worth or have you done that yet I've
done it yeah
$35,000 so it's worth 35 you owe 46 so
10K upside down yeah 9k all right um
we're going to deal with that we're
still getting out of this car cuz at
this point
40,000 is worth it to take a $10,000 hit
so we're going to talk about that why oh
real quick why are you only making
$20,000
man um well uh I don't know how to do
msh um that's not true don't I don't
believe that for one
second not for one second yeah that's
not
true yeah can you deliver pizzas yes can
you drive Uber yes can you go find a
construction site of all those building
sites out in Houston and just throw
brick yes hey yeah yes you don't want to
work you're going to work tomorrow right
and you think that what you know how to
do is not important and it is important
because that's what's going to keep food
on your table that's what's going to pay
off your debt it is so
important yeah I agree are you so let's
let's change that hey are you in manuell
yeah I'm in okay we we believe in you
and we can't believe in you more than
you believe in you okay yes sir yeah
okay uh we're locking that in so $20,000
I know you're working to get your D your
you know to so you can drive trucks CDL
but in the meantime there's almost
anything that you can do is going to
make you more than $20,000 McDonald's if
you're working 40 plus hours a week and
I want you working I mean are you a
single guy do you have
kids uh well I have a girlfriend that
don't
count that doesn't count Felicia and
look in this season we're eating at home
in this season it's McDonald's at home
and it's Bob cuz you don't have any
money okay and let her understand like
hey right now I've got to focus on
getting my life together I don't have
the money to do to I I like you a lot
but I don't have the money to just be
taking you out to whining and dining you
not that you're doing that much anyway
on 20,000 but I certainly don't want you
using a credit card to do that so the
game changes today we're going to get
another job any job I want you doubling
your income in the next month or two all
right and you can do that we're doing
that that's a yes all right yeah next
thing is I want you out of this car
how's your credit I'm guessing it's in
the toilet yeah it's terrible I
completely destroy my credit when I took
all these loans and I'm actually miss
payments already I just can't afford to
make those uh to make some payments
anymore on my credit cards and personal
loans yeah I need you so are you current
on the car or you're behind I'm current
on my car uh just because I need the car
I live in a big city I need to move
around can you go sell that motorcycle
this weekend for 5,000 bucks 100% I'm
also upside down on the motorcycle I
don't care how much how far uh they only
give me like 3,000 I owe 5,000 so I'm
like two grand upside if I were you I
would try to get I would try to find the
difference um if you can't get a loan or
a personal loan I try again this is the
one time I'd suggest a credit card see
if you can find you know a 10 or $15,000
balance so you can get out of this car
give them the 10,000 clear the Gap then
take 5,000 to get you a cash car you're
buying buy a car in cash do your
research get the best car that you can
get and you're going to be $40,000 Less
in debt sound
good yeah I I mean I've tried that
already I used to work at a dealership
for like two years and um I know how the
I know how that works it's just that I I
I there's no way nobody will give me a
loan for that uh I've tried selling I've
tried getting a loan for so I can get
another car and drive it around but you
know I'm just too deep in the hole I
guess all right then the next the next
play is I want you to look deeper into
that but the next play here is you've
got to get your income up because at the
end of the day here's what here's what
we know is true you can pay debt off as
long as you stop creating debt you can
dig yourself out of the hole when my
husband and I started out with debt man
well I want you to hear this we made
30,000 combined we had
$460,000 of debt when I tell you things
are possible it's possible but it
demands you getting stupid on this debt
it demands you working working so hard
to get your income up and I'm not
talking about overnight this is year
over-year month over month gains you're
growing you're getting better you're
earning more money you're decreasing
what you spend and over time your life
is going to change you're seeing the
value and what you put out into the
world and that's what I need you to get
out of this call you can do it when it
comes to your money you can tell me that
you won't do it but don't tell me that
you can't this is the ramsy
show hey what's up guys it's Jade if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw joined
by John deloney we're taking your calls
all afternoon your life your money your
mental health give us a call the number
is
8825 5225 we're happy you're here we're
happy that you trust us with your
situations thank you for doing that and
uh let's go straight to the phone lines
we got Carlos in Los Angeles California
what's going on
Carlos hi can you guys hear me we can oh
perfect hi well actually I can't believe
I'm on this gu I just I discovered you
guys uh like last week last Thursday
YouTube and the podcast yeah so what do
you think so far welome to our crazy
gang
yeah man and I literally fall asleep
like last week and let me give you a
backstory so I've been listening to you
guys non-stop since last week you know
I'm I'm 31 fiance is 29 and on Saturday
we had a p of finances because I was
listening to you guys hey Carlos talk
hey hey Carlos talk directly into your
phone for me uhhuh oh okay sorry I
apologize um so we talk about site about
like having a
budget maybe she was angry at the time I
can't hear you brother are you are you
on speaker phone hold on Carlos Carlos
can't hear you man
Carlos
Carlos Carlos can't hear you brother we
can't hear you hey we might have to come
back to you in a minute because we
really couldn't hear you next time uh
we'll get the call back but get off
speaker phone or wherever you were
getting better service and then we'll be
able to help you out until we get Carlos
back let's go to Brian in Philadelphia
what's up
Brian hey how are you good what's
up um so I just had a quick question I
don't really have any sort of um issue
with saving money but my question is
about uh student loan debt uhuh um I got
lucky with it and I got half of my
college paid for and I went to a cheap
School sweet um so I only have about
12,500 um I have more than enough saved
up where I could just pay that off and
not have you know not have that debt
right but um I have not been making
payments on it due to the pause and
thinking that maybe um it'll be it'll be
canel or at least $10,000 so my question
is is it worth just tackling and
knocking out or is it a better idea to
just continue making payments and Brian
you love it does it make you feel warm
do you love
it do I love what the
loan I do not love the loan now like
when nobody's around do you go in like
your room and shut the door and just hug
it do you love it Brian the dream of the
dream of forgiveness died several months
back pay it off right now what are you
doing pay it off and
and um I'm going to say something and it
might
sting okay um pay off your student loan
and and do it with knowing inside your
heart man this is awesome that I have
the money to pay this
off because so many folks call our show
and they don't have the money to pay it
off not today and not for a couple for
several years on down the line and when
you wait out for forgiveness people who
didn't even take out student loans or
have their own they're fitting the bill
and so when you have the money to pay
pay so that other people who didn't even
have student loans aren't going to have
to pay through any type of who knows
what'll come down the pipe you know next
election year or whatever maybe
somebody's going to talk about
forgiveness again but always remember
nothing is free like first rule of
Economics there's no such thing as a
free lunch right everything costs and it
costs the taxpayer and if you're a
person in this country that can pay the
bills that they signed up to pay pay it
you called the wrong two people cuz both
Jade and I paid off hundreds of
thousands of dollars and I'll tell you
right now Brian if if those if those
forgivenesses went through and Miss Jade
had to add that to her taxes I'd be
fired up cuz I already paid
280,000 you know what I'm saying Brian
yeah the part about the timeline and and
I definitely got your answer uh on that
and I kind of had a suspicion that you
might say that yeah um but I was
actually to pay it off and then right
when I was about to pay it off the whole
thing came up that it might just be
forgiven so I figured if I paid it and
then it immediately would have been
forgiven I would have thought to myself
I should have invested that money
elsewhere but you know I totally get
your point though I think there's a
bigger thing there's and I think we lose
this this I think we lose this um
globally there is a a psychological and
in turn a physiological response to
Integrity to standing up and keeping
your word telling the truth there's a
reason why truth telling is woven into
the fabric of every Faith tradition in
human history there you you walk
differently and when I was 18 and I
signed up for all the stupid loans I
signed up for I had no idea what I was
signing up for
Jade need I mean none of us did we were
just doing the next thing everybody told
us but we both put our names on a piece
of paper and said if you help me get
through school I'll pay you back you did
too and so I can see that you would have
been like dude I got $10,000 more
dollars in my pocket you know we got
bailed out by the government Jade's
right number one anytime any time a
government agency bails you out they
will come knocking for a piece of Flesh
at some point if you've ever sat in a
history class they will come back to
your door and say where's mine so always
count on that but the big thing is is
you would you would be like oh man I
should have invested it but I did what
was right because I put my name on a
piece of paper and I said I'd pay you
back and there you go here's my money
and I'm I'm moving on to the next and
you know what thanks for that call Brian
because we needed to talk about this
with with the people don't you think
that everyone would like to open up
their bills and go ah I'm not going to
pay
that I mean no one wants to pay their
bills no one wants to give away money
like it doesn't feel good and it doesn't
it's not fun especially when you didn't
realize what you're doing yeah
absolutely but I'm saying it's it's not
fun to write your check for your car pay
or you know pay online I'm sorry I just
aged myself no one wants to send that
online pay payment for their car but
they signed up to have a car payment no
one wants to send you know even though
this is a little bit better you know
your insurance payment you know and
you're like gosh I never even use this
thing and it's not fun to give away your
money but when you sign up for something
you you say that you're going to pay for
it and there is that piece of it that's
there and when it comes to these student
loans yeah I I can really get into this
here's the thing and I want to validate
this because I felt that John I'm sure
you have too with student loans is very
different because you're looking around
you're going yeah I was 18 somebody
should have stepped in like it would
have been nice if some adult had gone
hey Jade you don't need to take out that
much student loans because you know
you've got a full right scholarship you
don't need to take out student loans to
get your hair done and go to parties bu
groceries like that's dumb Jay don't do
that I would have loved if an adult did
that I would have loved if an adult
stood and really explained compound
interest to me when it's working against
you I would have loved that but nobody
did I would have loved so many things to
be different about that situation for
the people to say hey don't put your
loan on forbearance because when you do
that it's going to accumulate interest
in you faster than you've ever could
imagine no one did that and I can spend
my whole life blaming them or I can go
oh let me change my whole life I can't
blame my way to a better life I've got
to change the situation pay off your
debt that's all it is man this is the
Ramsay
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their one 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
thank you for listening to the Ramsey
Show I am Jade warshaw joined by
best-selling author Dr John deloney and
I'm actually really excited John because
you have a brand new book coming out
it's coming out Tuesday just a few days
just a few days that's right hey I'm
excited tell the folks about it building
a non-anxious life in a society and a
generation we have everything we're
anxious beyond measure anxious beyond
words and so wrote a book called billing
and non- anxious life and it's um it's
exciting to say it's breaking all the
internal pre-sale records and um it's
got just a couple more days when it gets
to Monday at midnight the um all the
pre-sale goodies will be gone and I
think it's 75 bucks they say of uh of
free stuff that that comes with it get
online Ramsey solutions.com or john.com
and pick it up and then come Tuesday
October 2nd October 3rd yeah third
October 3rd it will be in all the stores
all across America everywhere else but
I'm excited man let's get it out let's
get it out let's get out that's exciting
so can I just ask something of course
what store when this book comes out what
store are you like I want to go see my
book sitting on the shelf in this store
I was an old like man I used to live my
wife and I used to live in bookstores
and so going like seeing a book in a
Barnes & Noble's pretty Rad or walking
by and seeing it in a target's pretty
cool I mean it's just just see it it's
just surreal none of that surreal it's
just weird John I'm excited for you that
is super duper cool make sure to get
your copy I know I got mine ramsy
solutions.com that's where you want to
get it let's go to John and Washington
and by the way if you want to take a
call if you want us to take your call
give us a call 8825 5225 and we will do
just that without further Ado we got
John in Washington DC what's going on
John hey guys uh thank you for taking my
call absolutely how can we help um so I
I I had a quick question so um so my
wife and I um um recently actually just
paid off my student loan and we're
completely debt free now except for our
mortgage way to go yeah that's a slow
clap right there good job yes and we
we've been uh listening to ramy's um
show for a long time so um you guys help
turn my mindset around to do this the
right way love that um so I'm that note
like we're we were thinking about so we
we currently own a condo in this area
and um we have a baby and we're going to
be putting her into dayare in about a
month or two and it's kind of expensive
um in the area so um but we've also been
looking at houses because we really want
to own a home but we are not sure if
that is a smart idea um uh we make
decent amount of money but we're we're
not sure we can really afford it and
with the interest rates going up and
prices just keep Rising we just feel
like we're never going to be able to
attain a home and uh we're not sure
we're just looking for some advice on
what you guys think we should do yeah
and how we should plan for the next
steps to hopefully own a home in the
future yeah absolutely I think you're
asking all the right questions and I
think you got the right uh set of
Weights in place it's like okay we got a
baby we got daycare coming up yes we'd
love to have a home all great questions
to ask um my first question to you
because if we do do the math and figure
out yeah you guys are ready that's great
but I want to make sure that you've got
a couple of things in place do you guys
have an emergency fund fully funded
three to six months of
expenses yes yes we have um um we have
savings um but I mean I just spent about
like $40,000 to pay off my student loans
okay so what do you have
left so we have about um I'd say about
50,000 um in a savings account probably
another 16 stocks um and we probably
have around
another um I would say 80 in retirement
accounts okay so you've got 110 that's
non-retirement
right yeah okay so that's great um I
would knock that down or siphon it off
in your brain to whatever 3 to 6 months
of your expenses are so are you a person
who you feel would need three months to
feel comfortable of emergency expenses
if one of you were to lose your job or
six
months I would say six months for six
months okay so if just quickly in your
head basic expenses I'm not talking
about a full and by the way for anyone
listening when we talk about an
emergency fund it's not your full budget
time six it's what you really need to
just keep your home running all right if
everything gets down to the wire right
only what you need to survive that
doesn't include the restaurant budget
and nails and you know if your wife gets
her lashes done that doesn't include all
of that it's this is your basic what it
take barebones budget 3 to six months
what would that be for you for six
months probably like 20K I think oh only
20K okay are you
sure well so like our mortgage right now
is about like 2500 MH um and probably
other monthly expenses if we really had
to cut back probably could go to like
500 to a th000 a month oh wow y'all are
living y'all are Living Lean um okay put
30 in there for fun thank you I was
going to say just for me can you keep it
at 30 put 30 in there for fun let's go
with 30 I'll feel better about that um
okay so 30 set aside that gives you
880,000 coming up uh to start putting
towards a down payment okay so now what
we want to think about here is how to
buy a house to where it's a blessing for
you and it's not a burden all right
which is you're going to have to do your
research and I really want you to run
the numbers we've got on Ramsey
solutions.com we've got a mortgage
calculator you can check out or you can
just Google um how much home can I
afford Ramsey Solutions calculator pop
up right there but at the end of the day
here's what I want you to aim for John I
want you on a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage write this down 15year fixed
rate mortgage I don't want the payment
to be any more than 25% % of your
take-home pay now this is your take-home
pay after taxes only all
right see that's the problem right now
because I feel like that that payment
that I would calculate so like I've been
listening to you guys and I know the
whole 15 year old 15 year Rule and all
that right now we have a 30- year old a
30- year old 30-year mortgage and our
monthly with principal interest taxes
and everything PMI is like 2500 right
and even that feels hard for us and
that's I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna be
honest with you yeah your payment your
payment for what you get is going to be
higher because you're cutting it in half
you're saying I'm not going to pay for a
home for 30 years I'm going to pay for a
home in 15 years and if you do it our
way it's going to be even less do you
know let me tell you something John the
folks who walk through our steps they
become debt-free they pay off their
house in the next 7 to 10
years cuz the goal here the goal of
everything we teach this is not just for
you for anyone listening the goal here
is Ultimate peace and the way you get to
Ultimate peace is there's no payments so
we want you to pay off your home if you
get a 30-year mortgage at that point
what you're saying is I'd rather have
more space I'd rather have a bigger home
I'd rather have all of these things
rather than having the piece of owning
my home not to mention when you don't
have a home payment do you know how
freaking rich you're going to be because
how much you're going to be investing
every month John talk to about it well
John what what are you do in Washington
Washington
DC uh so I'm an engineer and my wife uh
works for a a company as a um she's a
legal professional okay so this is a
conversation that millions and millions
and millions of Americans are having
right now which is
this we really wanted this particular
job in this particular field in this
particular City could be because we want
to be New York people we love the energy
of DC we love the the legal profession
here we love the X the W
great what we're telling you is the math
doesn't work in your favor and the
question you and your wife have to ask
and it needs to be like in an
intentional fun where let's go get
breakfast together and get some a sitter
for the kids or for the
kid it's a dreaming conversation but
it's a hard conversation which is what
do we want more do we want to have
access to concerts four minutes away and
do we want to live by the subway do we
like the quote unquote energy of the
city or we want a
home because the world needs legal
professionals you're an engineer you can
get a job all across America and you can
cut your living expenses by
2/3 right and you can get a house for
for in some places for half you know
you're 50% there um with just your down
payment depending on what city and state
you move to so the harder question is
what are we willing to give up for this
dream of owning a home what we're
telling you is mathematically speaking I
don't care about how you feel about it
cuz I know you want one we all do you
cannot afford it given what you make
where you live you'll have to deal with
that
[Music]
reality
[Applause]
you're listening to the Ramsey show this
is Jade warshaw this is John deloney
we're taking your calls all afternoon
John what's coming around the pipe all
right we got two big things going on
October 5th this is next Thursday I'm
throwing a book release bash we're going
to have punk rock music and singer
songwriters and a PO it's going to be D
it's going to get off the rails they
gave me one hour to plan whatever I
wanted and it's going to be a blast um
we're going to have a we're going to
have a about an hour program and then
I'm going to sign books and um take
pictures until every single person is
ready to go so um that's October 5th
let's up um go to ramsy solutions.com
for that and our first ever money and
marriage getaway October 19th through
21st in Nashville me and Rachel Cruz
we're going to equip you and your spouse
with tools to cast a vision for your
family set goals create a life that you
both love we're going to be talking
about money we're going to be talking
about sex we're going to be talking
about everything that couples are
struggling with right now and we're
going to have a ton of opportunities for
you
to get one-on-one or two-on-one direct
coaching and conversations it's not
going to be us lecturing this is going
to be more conversational more um think
think graduate school not um huge
lecture hall right they're gonna be
interactive sessions and me and Rachel
Cruz are gon to be your guys to discuss
communication boundary sex money all of
it tickets are 799 bucks it's a whole
weekend it's going to include a great
fun event um one one of the nights it's
just going to get off the rails also if
you're out of debt you got room in the
budget please come see us Ramsey
solutions.com
events and we have couples who have been
married a few months and we have couples
who been married 20 30 years who are
circling back and say okay we want the
back half of our marriage to be more
awesome than our first half and so we've
got people from all over the Spectrum
hope you'll join us ramsy solutions.com
events like that let's go to Detroit we
got Kylie what's going on
Kylie hi there thanks for taking my call
you bet what's going on okay so my
husband and I are in a situation um so
right now we are just not making end
meet meet we're in the negative every
month and I'm trying to figure out if we
F bankrupt or if we I don't we don't see
another way so we're just trying to
figure that out right now so the bills
that you have we're not paying the bills
that we have and I'm assuming there's
debt as well right yeah so we have that
we can so we we're paying our bills we
we're not behind on like food house
electricity any of we're we're doing the
taking care of ourselves and you're
paying minimums on the debt as well yes
okay yep so can you kind of list out the
debt for us yes so we have um 880,000 in
student debt okay which we're we we're
not paying on and I'm in school so it's
all deferred um not that does exist but
are you still acre hold on are you still
AC crewing student loan debt um I think
technically it opens up this weekend
right no I mean you said you're still in
school so I'm saying are you still
continuing to take I am getting y girl
we G to talk about that we're we'll talk
about that let's take it one thing at a
time though so so far we've got the
80,000 in student loans what else yes um
and we have 30,000 in personal loan it's
there's 25 personal loan and then um
another 5,000 is credit cards okay and
so you're in school are you working at
all while you're in school I I work um
part-time from home we have four kids
and we homeschool oh wow part-time from
home four kids you're homeschooling what
are you earning working part-time from
home um I bring home around 21,000 a
year okay and what is your husband
earning um he is making right now he
just got a new job in his new degree
field um and he's only making 36,000 a
year what is he
doing he's doing software support so he
went and like got his it and coding
stuff and he couldn't find a better
job yet when I hear what the coders are
pulling in in this building it makes me
wish I'd gone to coding school
that's what we
also thought but I mean we would take
any leads
okay here's when you tell me your income
my brain goes to the average income the
median income in America and I I'm
always striving to to get people at
least to the median all right which is
around 67,000 just to know like all
right I'm in the game so yeah I really
want that to be your goal very very
quickly um you got $115,000 in debt um
if we want to make this needle move the
secret sauce here is getting the income
up and running like cranking
and the thing that I the thing that I
want you to understand is you're you
can't solve a problem while
simultaneously creating it and right now
you're still adding to the debt and so
any movement that you make forward is
going to feel futile so what I want to
do is stop the bleeding and so you're
going you're going to school now what's
the endgame of this this um so I'm in my
Master's to be as a licensed
counselor okay how much time is left and
how much more money is being added to
this bill um how much time is left like
three to four years I'm doing very
part-time and I I honestly don't even
know the end like probably at least
another 50 can I say something really
hard don't do
that can I say it John I'm I'm I dude I
I've got a PhD in counseling I'm G tell
you don't do it I was a I was a graduate
school Professor here's why I'm telling
you that 50,000 on top of the other 80
for a clinical mental health counseling
degree is going to be a nightmare to pay
off and dude I was a graduate school
Professor I need more counselors out
there I want people to go to graduate
school and get their counseling degrees
here's the deal you're broke y'all can't
afford this and you got four kids yeah
you have to make some radical hard hard
choices
like we want the idea of schooling all
four of our kids maybe they got to go to
public school for a couple years where
we clean up the mess that the adults in
the house made my husband really wants
to be a coder but he can make about that
much money being an assistant manager at
McDonald's right now he's G to go find a
job and a second one too y'all are in a
situation and I think you want to have I
want to be a licensed therapist dude I
want that so bad for you we want to
homeschool our kids I so badly want that
for you want him to be a coder cuz they
keep saying we're going to make $200,000
I want that for him too but the reality
is those things aren't real right now MH
what is real is y'all can't breathe
because um you owe so much money and let
me tell you this and you probably
learned this in your grad school classes
already your children absorb the tension
in your home yeah and if Mom and Dad
can't pay bills then Mom and Dad are
struggling with each other and those
kids are absorbing that every second of
every
day see what I'm saying and so sometimes
it's a Dream Deferred several times in
my second doctoral program I had to quit
I took off a semester because I had to
take care of things at home I had to
take care of things with me and my wife
and so it may be the time and there's
going to be a state school that I
promise you can get a great clinical
master's degree that's going to be
infinitely cheaper than what you're
doing and you'll be able to pay cash as
you go this I know it's hard but I you
and your husband aren't being yall
aren't dealing with reality and and I
don't mean that like you're not living
on the moon y'all just don't make enough
money and you want to do this and you
want to do this you want to do this um
if you put all four of your kids in
public school on Monday day and you went
to work full-time you instantly are able
to breathe
instantly and if he says three of them
are too young for school but yeah okay
but you know you get you get the sense
of what I'm saying right um and or you
reach out to somebody at the local
church and you get some help or you take
your parttime job and and your you look
at your husband say you're making 36
Grand you were trying to get off the
ground with this great and I know you
want to be around with all four kids
great but we have to have more money
right now yeah there is going to be a
sacrifice there's going to be TR no way
there's not a sacrifice there's going to
be a sacrifice going to be a trade and
that's based on what you say the
priority is I mean we can say this is a
money show and this you know John's
going to speak to the other side of it
but we're always going to
prioritize what gets you feeling peace
and feeling freedom first and I think a
lot of times people think oh like
probably in your mind you're like oh
I'll get my degree I'll be able to earn
more money and that was the path but
then you pull back and you're like wait
a second this is just creating more like
frustration more debt more chaos and
when that happens you do have to stop
and regroup and go okay what was the
price priority again what was the thing
cuz it can't everything can't be A1 if
everything's A1 then you start going
crazy really quickly yeah and so
something something goes on the chopping
block and that's the really really hard
part of this conversation uh not just
for you Kylie but for so many folks
listening thank you for the call because
I think just by you sharing your story
it provides Clarity for a lot of people
cuz John you're so right you have to
make hard choices very rarely in life do
you get to just get all of it at once
well and you mentioned something goes on
The Chopping Block and if you don't want
it to be your degree it doesn't want you
don't want to be your career dream it
will be your marriage yeah it will be
your relationship with your kids yeah it
will be your peace something has to pay
the piper and so let it be the adults in
the house that is such a good word uh
yeah you got to make the sacrifice and
you know what sometimes I don't like the
word sacrifice John I like to call it a
trade cuz it's really what are you
trading what are you getting in return
and when you say it like that it has I
don't know a better ring to it this is
the ramsy
[Applause]
show
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsy show I am
your host Jade warshaw joined by
bestelling author Dr John deloney host
of the Dr John deloney show love to say
that and uh I wanted to let you new
folks listening know that if you're
listening number one we're happy that
you're here but number two you probably
hear us talk about things all the time
that you're like hey I'm new here and I
feel like you guys are using some inside
jargon some lingo that I don't
understand help me understand and and if
that's you I want you to go to ramsy
solutions.com and I want you to click
that little get started button because
that's where we're going to meet you
where you're at we're going to explain
this whole thing to you we're going to
talk to you about the baby steps we're
going to explain what all that means and
finally you're going to feel like you've
come into the fold the ramsy fold and
you're going to go oh my gosh I get it
now I loved the show before but I love
it even more now that I understand all
the things that they're talking about so
do that today go to ramsy solutions.com
click the get started button and uh
we'll help you figure out your best Next
Step here with Ramsey Solutions that's
amazing in the meantime let's go to
Michael he's in Scottdale Arizona
Michael what's going on buddy hey I had
a quick question for you guys I was
wondering at what point do you sell um
stocks and mutual funds to payoff baby
step number two uh I've made a oopsy
last year and we're probably about 65%
over an individual stock purchase um
negative on that but at what point do we
just just cut our loss sell it pay off
baby step two and just move on yeah are
you doing
man what what were you doing did you did
you get like an Insider tip did you like
read a magazine no absolutely not it was
an IPO opening and I was like a this is
going to do well and it did not but oh
man you put all you pushed all your
chips in on that bet how hey I love the
way you said it was like it's just an
oopsy so it was either like 100 Grand or
it was 4,000 bucks what was the oopsie
it was ,000 bucks I made an investment
and it's you know down to about 4,000
now so um and how much is the
debt um I've got about 60,000 uh in debt
right now um shoot yeah okay so I'm the
way you framed it was as though if you
sold the 4,000 in stocks or whatever
what it was in stocks that that would be
enough to clean up the debt is there
more money because you also said mutual
funds yeah I've got mutual funds just
some Savings in general probably um with
all that combined of maybe 35 40,000
okay and that's non-retirement
non-retirement accounts so we're close
to just paying off the debt and with our
income we probably can clear it in the
next you know six to eight months or so
so I'm just trying to it's hard to let
go of a loss like
that maybe the market will go up but
that's the whole game right it never
does or when you need it well in this
case I mean over time it's going to go
up and if this was sitting in a
retirement account I'd be like yeah it's
fine let it let it ride but in this case
you're trying to pay off your debt and
so I would definitely say go ahead and
liquidate that money there's going to be
a tax implication on it for sure but in
this case it's it's worth it to you to
clear this debt you're still going to
have about 15 16,000 left that you need
to pay and I it sounds like you'll be
able to cash flow that and get the rest
of that out of your life pretty
quickly yeah it it is yeah how much you
said you and your partner H can do it in
eight six to eight months how much do
youall
make uh we make we own our own business
we make upwards of uh about 220 a year
wait a second good God Almighty how do
you not have this paid off by
Christmas you know what I know cuz
Michael's playing Michael you're over
here playing games aren't you Michael
you're playing games you're like I'mma
do a little of this I'mma do a little of
that it's so hard sometimes to you know
I don't know just not hang on to it
right and just kind of finally you know
I just finally kicked in um you know a
few months ago of like gosh let's get
this out of here why is it here why do
we have this debt let's build you know
this freedom and wealth and you know so
I'm just trying to I I I would love to
see you cash everything out and pay the
stuff off this weekend and have a huge
celebration like do it right I'm for
real and then you and your partner look
at each other and you'll have um October
November and December and say for
Christmas our Christmas present is let's
owe nobody anything let's have an
entirely free household we're free we
are free hey what's left to go on the
mortgage uh quite a lot we purchased a
home in uh the peak of
2022 and um but we we did gain a ton of
of equity in our previous home and so
you know we just kind of transfer that
over but we do we've got $675,000 okay
you make 225,000 so you're going to put
that on a seven-year plan you'll be done
in five yeah that and and thank you John
for getting to that because that's the
picture that I want to paint for you
going forward because I think you're a
smart guy I think you're a guy I mean
you've got a great income you've kind of
been dibbling and dabbling here and I
kind of want to give you the framework
for how you can do that in a way that's
going to give you peace and make the
most sense I mean hopefully you're
investing 15% of your income into
retirement is are you doing that or more
yeah we are I've got automation of our
you know our business just pays into our
into our plans and I'm trying to
automate that I've already put in a
thousand more towards princip of the
home just to do it you know just to say
it's starting to go in that and let's be
very intentional about that I mean over
here we would say invest 15% for
retirement and if you had kids put some
in the 529 and then you know be
intentional it doesn't have to be
everything that's extra going to the
house it doesn't have to be super
intense but be super intentional you
know like you said make it automated
every month this is the plan sit down
with your wife we putting x amount of
dollars towards the mortgage and before
you know it that mortgage is going to be
gone on and you're going to have the
extra money to play around with
investing more and if you want to do
single stocks it's like look I I've
always talked to Dave about that I'm
like Dave when's the best time to do
single stocks he's like look if you want
to play around with stuff like that as
long as it's no more than 5% of your
total net worth like whatever knock
yourself out but I think it's good to
that's only you have enough money to
burn in the middle of the living room
right yeah I mean exactly you did like
you he's going to have money to burn
he's going to have he's going to be a
he's going to have his home paid off at
600 it's worth 6 75 now right so it's
going to be skyrocketed by then so does
that does that sound like more fun
Michael it certainly certainly does yes
good good I appreciate the encouragement
and the extra push will you call us back
at Christmas on on December 24th we have
a we have a like a show right before it
just to do your debt free
scream I'm challenging you I'm giving
you a 90day challenge oo I appreciate
that I will um I'll talk to my wife and
we'll we'll work hard to get that then I
love that it's like Yoda stuff there is
no try 90
days come on Michael you make a quarter
million
dollars yeah do it do look thank you
Michael for the call and hey keep
listening because this next thing I'm
going to talk about is kind of about you
and not just you Michael but so many
people let me tell you the most
dangerous place to be in John is when it
it it comes in a couple of ways in his
case he's got a nice income and his debt
is there but it's not rocking his world
it's not making him duck and Run for
Cover right or somebody who makes maybe
$120,000 a year and they've got 20
$25,000 of debt it's not like they're
not shooketh right they're just like
I've got this debt it's a little
annoying but I'll make it work King
James shook shth they're not shooketh
when you got Sam and Jade type debt to
ratio income you are under the ground
you're running for your life you don't
have a choice and so I those are those
calls are always the hardest cuz it's
like I can bat It Around the Net a
little bit longer for now for now and
those are the ones that you look up in 5
years down the line 10 years down the
line suddenly it starts eating a hole
bigger and bigger because you can't out
earn bad spending habits you can for a
little while but after a while it
catches up with you and it's going to
bite it's going to take a big old chunk
out of your booty can I say that online
you can and you say probably whatever we
want online but also I always again I
always feel like I'm Debbie Downer it
just takes one shift in the market one
thing that that Scottdale decides to do
with a regulatory issue and your
business is over yeah and you have a
$600,000 mortgage that was a great deal
cuz you rolled $300,000 in equity into
it I don't care yeah and now you've got
60,000 bucks and you can't eat right it
happen we would not have a show if it
didn't happen that's not going to happen
to me I'm an engineer I'm a AI is coming
for you I've got I'm a this it's coming
for you right so be very very I love how
cancer is cancer whether it's a lot of
cancer or a little cancer you got to
deal with it you got to deal with it
because that thing will grow and at the
end of the day really what it's about is
the habits that you're forming you know
when you say ah I know I can't afford
that I put on the credit card I'll be
able to pay it off right those are
habits that you're forming every day and
so what we're teaching it's so that you
ingrain better habits so that over time
you're building a better Financial
Foundation it doesn't have to just be
this one F swoop thing we want the daily
choices that you make ah daily choices
see what I did there we want that to be
what shapes your financial future so
that's how it works Michael thanks for
the call you helped us you helped a lot
of other folks thanks for listening that
does it for this hour we'll catch you
next
hour hey it's Dr John delone if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to Ramy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it is the Ramsey show
where we help people build wealth we
help them do work they love and create
actual not fake actual amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw your
co-host joined by Dr John deloney to my
right we're taking your calls for the
next hour we'll talk about your life
your money your mental health you can
give us a call 8825 5225 and we will do
our best to answer your questions and
number one I always grateful that you
guys even trust us with your life like
you guys call in you're willing to share
your numbers you're willing to share
your deepest darkest secrets we
definitely do not take that lightly so
thank you so so much and um another
thing that we don't take lightly thank
you for watching thank you for listening
uh one of the things that you guys do
that's so incredible that we're so
grateful for uh is you share the show
and my I'm like can you just keep doing
that if you like the show click the
little like button if this has done
something for you subscribe or if you
know someone that would benefit from the
things that we're talking about in here
every day day go ahead and you know
share the episode with them slide them
the little paper airplane so they can
see it uh send them a you know link text
it to them that does so so much um not
only for us it does a lot for us because
it's great for the algorithm but it does
a lot for people because we exist here
to help you guys and help people and
that's our great privilege and honor so
thank you for doing that John I'm ready
to go to these phone lines because we
got Allison in Toledo Ohio Allison
what's going on
girl hi thank you for taking my call
doing good how are you I'm good um so my
question is I have a daughter that's
going to be going to college next fall
um the problem is she has been
struggling with an eating disorder for
five years um we've been through like
numerous therapists dieticians
residential stays uh she's stable but
nowhere near recovery um I don't want
her to go to college but her therapist
thinks I need to just kind of let her go
and I can't make her recover she doesn't
want that want to do that herself and I
guess I'm just scared because I'm afraid
she's gonna go and then
she's she's sorry yeah um she's gonna go
and then she's just GNA wither away and
I know I have a year away but I'm just
like terrified and I just don't know how
to deal with it no thank you for sharing
that
um o over the last two two decades I've
with a number of moms in your very
situation okay so you're not you're not
alone in that it's hard um and let's I I
always like to enter into these
conversations um especially in this kind
of format in a radio show um with as
much truth as possible is that cool yeah
okay you and I both know that disordered
eating is one of the if not the most
lethal Mental Health Challenge right
right it's not something to mess around
with and we also know that when our kids
are hurting we will do anything and
sometimes what we do ends
up we build
fences and in a weird way that can make
challenges for the growth and safety and
development and healing for some of
these challenges right until it becomes
this weird recursive I don't want to be
a part of the problem but my therapist
the therapist is saying I need to stop
doing this but I feel like I have to do
this and so here's what I would do um
okay is there a risk of sending her away
100% absolutely no question about that
anyone who tells you there's not they're
lying to you okay okay
and I have been a part of multiple teams
at multiple universities from a giant R1
research institution with 35 or 40,000
students at it to a small faith-based
community and the other universities in
between that with a parent and with a
student and with the right care team
what made up of of a nutrition
and made up of uh Mental Health
Providers on campus and sometimes
medical providers on campus there ends
up being an amazing team and then you
throw in residence hall directors and
the ability to make friends and get
community okay there is an opportunity
it sounds to me like you a have concerns
about her health and well-being which
are all true and you have a licensed
mental health professional saying in her
professional opinion this is the next
best right move that's number one number
two it ALS also sounds like you need to
do some
work dealing with the opening of your
hands and letting your daughter move to
the next stage of her life which is
scary to do is that fair yeah yeah and I
actually have been seeing a therapist
past month and I mean she says that too
she does good so um it's hard when when
a mental health professional tells me a
parent uh maybe you've got some stuff
you need to work on and I'm like no it's
they're the ones with and so follow
follow the wisdom of of the
Professionals in front of you okay and
I'm going to tell you to balance that
with go with your gut moms especially
but moms and dads are pretty intuitive
but if I'm sitting my kid and I'm in
your situation okay I have a
seven-year-old little girl and I
wouldn't wish it on her as you wouldn't
wish it on anybody but let's say I find
myself in the same situation what I
would do is sit down with the college
that my daughter's going to go to and we
would sit down with the there's going to
be a care team a student support and
emergency team it's going to be some
group of people that have a 360 degree
view of your daughter academically
residen H experience mental health
provider Etc and we're going to create a
plan and everybody's going to be a part
of that plan and a part of that plan
will be the school will call you if they
get really concerned about the health
and safety of your
daughter okay okay so do you think a
smaller school would be a better choice
then um I think there's going to be I I
I wouldn't say that because because they
may not have the resources of a larger
school so I don't I don't know that I
think it's going to be very specific to
your individual situation and where your
daughter feels like she is going to be
safe and where she's going to have a
good experience um and here's the deal
I'm not special guys like me men and
women like me all across the country
chair these teams I ched one of these
teams at several different places okay
so if you can just imagine a knucklehead
like me sitting down saying okay do we
have the right therapist the Right
medical provider we've got the right
people here and then the work on the
other end is let the professionals do
their job and
Mom you do the work on opening your
hands up and letting your daughter who's
now an adult slowly transition into
adulthood okay which stinks I know did
you want me just to say no keep her home
don't ever let her grow up would that
have been so much easier no no I just
I've been trying to be so strong we're
going this college visits and I'm being
like really excited for her but like
inside I'm a nervous wck you can be
both okay and hey I think it's fair to
tell your daughter I love you to the
moon and back and there's nothing in the
world other than maybe your dad that I
love more than you and so I'm your mom
it's going to be hard on me divorced oh
you're divorced okay so no so in many
ways she might have been your identity
for a long time
right yeah has she been your purpose and
reason for being yeah she's been
propping you up for a long time and it's
going to you're going have to tell her
I'm going to have to work to let you go
and so it's going to be hard for me your
mom it's not her job to make you feel
better that's not her job ever ever ever
that's your job to do that kind of work
right right and so I would be honest
with her be honest with her she's smart
she's going to college she's smart and
she loves her mom and also um trusted
Professionals in in in her world there's
going to be a whole team of them if you
pick the right school I'm proud of you
for going to counseling on your own too
this a hard hard hard season you're
going through this is the ramsy show
[Music]
if you have questions with your money
questions about your budget questions
about college choice questions about
mental health choices you're feeling
anxious about money anxious about
student loans coming back if the
national debts got you feeling some type
of way if the debates have you feeling
some type of way man give us a call we
want to talk about all of that you'd be
surprised at how all of these things
filter into our choices that we make
with our life and our money and if we're
not aware of that on Down the Line we'll
look up and be like oh my gosh I've
created a mess so if any of those things
are on your mind give us a call the
number is 88255 225 we'll help sort it
out with you it would be our great place
pleasure let's go to Matt in Mesa
Arizona what's going on
Matt hi thanks for taking my call you
bet hey um exactly what you were saying
there um some of those things you know
inflation and cost come on it's real
right factor in yeah they factor in but
my questions um specifically with
Bitcoin and I I'll get to it but where
my wife and I are at
is um through baby step four so we're
completing um contributing 15% to our
retirement account and then the next
steps are obviously the 529 or college
savings and paying off the house right
uh we're not there salary-wise to start
contributing to five and six yet uh
maybe in a couple years with a raise
we'll start doing that but we have about
a Bitcoin in uh it just saved up so if
you cash it out after taxes it probably
be worth 20K would you but that's my
question for you uh relating to bitcoin
what would you do with that Bitcoin and
the situation that um that I'm in are
you guys how long have you hold how long
have you had
it since 2015 has it been so
fun yeah it's been a roller coaster it
seems like it's been like more of like a
backyard
slide yeah
I yeah so like just directly from top to
bottom I'm just glad you're ready to get
out of it dude I would sell it before
the day was over most definitely and um
you know you're you're contributing the
15% to retirement like you should be um
I'm not mad at you guys using that and
kind of putting a a chunk into the 529
if you wanted to do that because that is
important how many kids do you have we
have a four-year-old and entally you
know another one next year which might
be some of that savings if if we cash it
out sa some of that for another kid yeah
when it comes to the 529 uh we don't
have many hard and fast rules on the
amount that you have to contribute and
how often you should contribute and all
those things because the fact of the
matter is everybody's situation with
their kids when it comes to their
education is going to be different and
you're at the stage where you really
can't predict it at all like you know
you don't know if they're going to grow
up to want to do ivy league or if
they're going to do the trades or if
they're a musician and they just want to
rock out you like you don't know what
that's going to be and so as a parent
it's really up to you to choose the best
option I don't know that I would start
with 20,000 that just feels like a lot
and once you're in it you're kind of
locked in now not obviously down the
line that money can re can you know
convert into retirement money and it can
go to different siblings so that's a
conversation between you and your wife I
do want you to be contributing something
into that 529 but also know that four
five and six um if possible should be
done simultaneously so I'm not mad at
the idea of taking some of that money
and putting it into the 529 to get it
rolling and then taking the rest of it
and throwing it towards the mortgage how
much do you owe on your
mortgage um 235 235 you know that's up
to you there's not a wrong answer on
this if it were me if I woke up in your
shoes if I woke up in your shoes I might
reverse engineer it a little differently
I'd probably throw like a th000 into the
529 and be like okay every year I'm
going to put x amount of dollars in and
I'd probably put the bigger chunk toward
the mortgage that's what I would do and
maybe even have a contest with your wife
and see if y'all could get down to where
it was
199,999 bucks before Christmas or
something like that it just feel good
right yeah oh yeah when you get to when
you get below the z z Oh you start
making those moves and so I I that's
that's probably what I would do how what
what did you buy into Bitcoin what was
your initial Buy in uh I bought half for
300 bucks okay and then a whole one for
1,500 bucks I I already got my money
back okay you're good yeah I I love that
you're just willing to sell it I think
that's the right move as far as what
percentages to put where I don't think
there's a wrong answer but I think I
don't think there's a wrong answer in my
mind what feels a little bit more wise I
hate to use the word wise what feels
like there's less um unknown let me put
it like that is you know you've got to
pay your house off um you know you
that's that's a given you know you want
to have some money set aside for some
further education of your child you
don't know what that's going going to be
yet so it's not like we have to have
150,000 set aside for school you don't
know that you know so there is some
thought with that you might say hey
we're going to put 20,000 in we're going
to set it and forget it and let it grow
and what it is it is so those it
actually Sparks um Matt some bigger
conversations about education and you
and your wife sitting down and going
okay what's our goal here uh 529 is
great yeah we want to add to it but what
are we saying we're going to contribute
are we saying we're going to match them
dollar for dooll regardless of how they
further their education is our plan that
we're going to fund whatever that thing
is 100% is our plan is you know so I
think that's honestly the first
conversation and then whatever you guys
come away from that conversation will uh
lead you down if you're going to put
most of it towards a mortgage or put
most of it towards a 529 and I'll say
this too I spent most of my career in
higher ed and I've got a 13-year-old
who's just a few years out and I've got
a seven-year-old
I
am I have not a a single doubt in my
mind that what I know to be college and
the university experience right now will
be different for my
seven-year-old yeah so that's where
we're at we're conflicted on um what to
do in that situation so I I think you're
right it makes more sense to with any
extra cash pay down the house and even
having grandparents that would more than
likely step in to help pay for some of
that college for a grand kid um I
wouldn't count on it yeah not planning
on that but um like you said not
necessarily wiser but maybe the more for
sure thing is to pay down the mortgage
so and again start with that
conversation with your wife like set the
expectations so you know what the goal
is because it it's you know sometimes
with this stuff we just start throwing
darts and it's like hey I know I'm
supposed to do something like that and I
know I'm supposed to do something like
that and it's like H throw ,ll in there
throw $500 in there but what really
motivates us and what really makes us
feel awesome about what we're doing is
when we know exactly what we're aiming
towards and why then as you get closer
it's like that's freaking awesome like
we're really doing something so that's
what I'd say Matt feel good about it
thank you yeah I think the the mindset
has changed after having a kid and just
kind of settling down a little bit where
we want to have more peace with our
finances than being you know kind of no
kids or uh before that single and and
I've never needed the Bitcoin but I
think that's it's hard to have the
mindset of well so volatile it could go
up 200,000 and it could also go down and
so I don't really want to sell it which
is kind of why I'm calling in yeah but
uh having peace with with finances is
probably more important for us so I'll I
have that confirmation conversation with
my wife and and uh go from there I think
I think it's worth it look you guys are
out of debt number one so it's not like
I'm like sell this to get out of debt um
what's your net worth by the way like
what do you what else do you have
invested I'm just curious uh good
question um Beanie Babies we always say
like things like this Bitcoin and and
single stocks and um little things like
that that you just are dabbling around
in you don't want that to be more than
5% of your big picture and you certainly
don't want to be putting money into
those things currently until after baby
step 7even until after you're you know
doing all the doing all the important
things right then it's like when you
have money to play if you have money to
play um you might do stuff like that but
the way it sounded um you I feel like
when you first called in you said hey
we've got the money to do baby step four
but we don't necessarily have it to do
five and six and so I think that right
there was the the dial that you turned
that's like okay then it's it's time to
sell this off if you were like hey we're
just rolling in the dough should I just
go ahead and sell this to I'd probably
be like H who cares but because it does
matter to you and it matters in your
world I definitely would sell it I think
you're making the right choice I love
these conversations John yeah and I I
never want people to forget if you don't
have a mortgage can go a long way to
help cash flowing part of college 2 when
it comes around right oh yeah I mean
that's all that money freed up just
freed up money the mortgage is the
biggest piece of people's month-to-month
income and it's one thing when you go
from renting to ownership and it's a
whole other thing when you go from
ownership to no payments like I
literally own this free and clear you
can help cash flow a community college
with no problem oh that's what I'm
talking about this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
now
what's going on people it is the ramsy
show I am Jade warshaw your host I got
John deloney on the ones and twos to the
next to the next side of me remember
that when they used to say that I do I
do on the on and I don't even I don't
even know what that means I guess it
just means that you're uh I thought it
was the turntables yeah the ones and
twos though okay clearly I've never
worked a turntable um tables in a
microphone where it's at that's what I'm
talking about all right yes I got that
John I got that okay I know about Beck I
know what's going on here we're going to
go to Michaela in Honolulu Hawaii
Michaela what's going
on hi yeah so I'm just trying to see if
I can figure out a plan to help me and
my family get out of um like living
paycheck to paycheck yes ma'am you're
living in one of the most expensive
places on the planet is it rough yes it
yeah it's rough um but there's no no
room to leave like I'm not leaving this
is my home so I just have to figure out
what to do next um can you give us a
little bit of a can you give us a a big
picture of what's going on can you tell
us what the debt is can you tell us what
the income is would help you out yeah so
my husband has about $20,000 in student
loan debt um I'm at home with two kids
so I can't really work um how old are
the kids and then he um five months old
and two and a half
okay yeah and then um he makes about
like 50,000 okay um he just finished his
degree um so like he's looking for more
jobs and he got offered a management
position at his job so that he doesn't
leave so there's potentially more money
coming in um but I mean it's not going
to be significant enough to really make
a dent if you know what I mean at first
yeah I mean what are we talking he goes
from 50 to 55 or he
goes right yeah okay that's right and so
just the 20,000 in student loans is
there anything
else no okay um 20,000 in student loans
feels like a lot when you're making
50,000 um 20,000 in student loans feels
a lot better when you're making 70,000
880,000 right right so what we need to
do is we need to open that Gap a little
bit CU right now it's like man this is
almost half of my income and in the
United States you know the median income
is somewhere around 67,000 and I really
really really want to get you as close
to that as possible so you're staying
home with the kids I got to believe
there's something in this internet age I
believe I know Michaela there's
something that you can also be doing to
bring in some money right obviously
you're staying home with the kids CU
you're like hey it's too expensive to
put them in child care right did I guess
that right right yeah I mean it's also
just I can't let somebody else watch my
kids too you know wait a minute wait a
hold on hold on hold on you've told me
you can't move you've told me you can't
let somebody watch your kids you told me
you can't work and then you're calling
us I've started a you know I've started
a business so I'm trying to work
something that I can bring my kids with
to sell at uh our markets and stuff here
yes that's good can I got to cut you off
that's good but we need money today yeah
you're you're with your
ideas with the way things like your your
your non-negotiables are burying you
guys you don't have enough
money right and so you're gonna have to
you and your husband gonna have to give
like he wants to have this management
job cool I need you to go to McDonald's
and work the night shift because I'm
sure not working so you're going to have
to work two jobs or three jobs or I'm
going to start seeing keeping three of
my neighbor kids over at our house but
when you go into problem as desperate as
you're in we can't make the bills and
those little kids are absorbing your
husband's tension and your tension and
your
frustration and you go in with a whole
bunch of can't do that can't do that
can't do that can't do that that's a
tough way to solve a problem well you're
cutting you're cutting the legs out from
under you and it's not just you Michaela
we've been having this conversation all
afternoon with different callers
everything doesn't get the yes like
everything doesn't get to stay you do
have to go through and go hey yeah
everybody look not everybody but most
parents have the ideal scenario for
their kids and that's what they want I
would love you I wish I could bring my
kids to work and I could see them all
day every day but I can't do that and do
this job uh so there's there's a give
and take there um when Sam and I my
husband and I were getting out of debt I
wanted to be able to do what everybody
else does which is you know you come
home after a long hard day you know you
you order a pizza on a Friday you watch
Netflix I didn't get to do that because
we had to pay off our debt and so
there's part of this that you just go
okay I have to make changes and they
will be painful and I want people to
hear that it doesn't feel good when
you're paying off your debt it sucks it
hurts you sacrifice you strain and you
push yourself to limits that you're like
man I don't feel like the guy next to me
has to push himself to the type of
limits that I'm pushing myself to but at
the end of the day you turn into a
different person and that is that is the
pricee Michaela that's at the end of
this you turn yourself into a different
person number one that person's debt
free right but number two no one can
hold a candle to and no one can tell you
anything other than man like you're
confident like you can do what you say
you're going to do you can do hard
things you know how to prioritize you
know how to spend your time wisely that
builds something in you Michaela that is
going to be so Priceless and so
important throughout other because there
will be other storms in life and this is
going to create that well in you that
you're going to be able to dig from and
pull from and go hey remember when we
did XYZ remember when we doubled our
income and remember when we just fought
like dogs to get our income up remember
when we sacrificed everything and we
paid off that debt no one can take that
from you and so when you guys sit down
and you say okay what are we going to
sacrifice what are we going to do are we
going to do something with the kids what
does that look like am I going to get EX
am I going to put this dream I going to
defer this dream of whatever the
business you have for just a minute so I
can make some money to day it is going
to be so so worth it because when you
get to the point and you will get to
this point Michaela when you can keep
the kids home and when you can do some
of the things that you want to do it's
going to be that much more worth it
because you worked and sacrificed and
scrapped to get it how much H what's
been minimum wage on in h Honolulu right
now $12 I think it's 11 actually 11 what
um there I mean we couldve I worked at a
restaurant up until I had my child okay
um here's here's what I'm wondering what
does October 1st through March 1st what
is six
months what a six months of a family
member a friend someone from your church
or even a local daycare center watching
your kids six months of you grinding it
and hating every day of
it but you grind it and then after at
March 1st you don't owe anybody any
money right and then you are able to sit
with your kids and be fully present
without that Dragon hanging over your
shoulder and then by that time your
husband's moved from his management
position where it was just a little bit
of a raise to another position on the
island somewhere MH and what you're
talking about is 6 months and it feels
like a hundred years when you're holding
a five-month old but when I'm I have a
13-year-old now and I made some
sacrifices when he was young that allow
me and him to do some incredible things
that never would have happened
when me and my wife sat down and she
said Are you seriously going back to
school and I said I think I have to and
I don't know why but I think I have to
no idea that there was such thing called
a podcast and YouTube didn't exist right
at least in any way that I knew about it
and so there's something about saying
I'm just G to suck it up for a season
for right now so that I can do these
other things when you get that money
coming in it's going to change your life
you get that debt off your shoulder
changes your life you you find you find
a way to make $20,000 you know you can
live off so you're out of debt in a year
if you can make this work and hey before
you get off the line we're going to give
you every dollar that is the budgeting
app that we created here at Ramsey
Solutions it's the only budgeting app
that I use back in 2015 when my husband
and I were in the thick of it Ramsey was
like here you go we made every dollar
and we made it to make this easier for
you and I've never looked back we use
that thing it's so helpful it helps you
plot your goals it helps you see where
you're at and by the way Michaela I'm
going to be doing a webinar um on
October 10th uh it's at 11:30 Central
Time where I'm going to really walk
through paycheck to paycheck living how
to break that cycle like specifically
the things that you're talking about so
I really want you to tune into that
webinar um please please please make it
a priority and be there it's going to
help you it's an hour long it's a lunch
break uh and anybody else listening it's
open to the public I would love for you
guys to sign up for my webinar again
10:10 we're going to be going through
the every dooll app making sure you guys
really have a handle on how to use this
thing how it's truly going to help
youing break that paycheck to paycheck
cycle it's so important I'll see you
[Music]
there
you are listening to the Ramsay show I
am Jade he is John we are taking calls
about your life and your money the
scripture and quote of the day it says
Ecclesiastes Ecclesiastes 49 through1 he
says two are better than one because
they have a good return for their labor
if either of them falls down one can
help the other up but pity anyone who
falls and has no one to help them that's
a word right there Then Linda Grayson
said this there's nothing better than a
friend unless it's a friend with
chocolate look I ain't mad at that I
could use a little chocolate right now
John if you're my friend hey man you'll
find some I would love some chocolate
right now we don't have any um you know
I'm looking at the scripture
Ecclesiastes it says but pity the one
who Falls and has no one to help them
and it's kind of funny you and I were
talking during the break John we get
calls all the time and that I mean
that's what you call in right and you're
hoping that we can shed a little light
on your situation you're hoping that we
can say a couple of things that's going
to put you on the right track and and
and sometimes John folks call in and
they've already got a laundry list
prepared of a what they're not going to
do and B why it won't work right and
three what they can't do and what they
can't do and here's the thing and I said
this to John during the bre I'm just
being candid if you call in and you say
oh you know here's the thing I can't I
can't earn more um I can't move I can't
uh sacrifice this or that or that what
would happen if I just went oh oh okay
cool well sucks to be you then what if I
just you would not be okay with that you
would go well what kind of show is this
you guys are supposed to give me advice
you guys are supposed to help me move
move forward but here's the deal it only
works if you believe it works if we give
you a laundry list of things hey you
could try this you could do this uh
here's what worked for me here's what
worked for John and we're giving you
real life experience it's not a theory
we didn't just pull something out of our
butt and go hey try this you know it
might work for you we're telling you -
tested uh techniques when it comes to
money when it comes to life things that
not only worked for people out there
that you might not know or have ever
heard of but work we're people right
here in this studio who are telling you
hey uh look we sacrificed we slept on an
air mattress John pulled himself in and
out of school he made sacrifices to make
it work for his family we're telling you
that and you can either take it or you
can leave it right you lead a horse to
water but you can't make them drink but
here's the thing you came here for a
drink and we're trying to give you that
and um the belief thing it works either
way right whether you believe something
works or you believe it doesn't like
that's your choice so the things that we
have for you the resources that we have
for you you can make it true for you or
you can make it false for you you can
say hey like I believe this or I don't
and there's a big part of that like
you've got to you've got to connect to
that and you've got to stop saying I'm
the exception to the rule well and there
used to be a cultural ethos of we can do
anything yes we can go to the Moon we
can we can go liberate Europe we can go
fight this war we can do these things
and now our cultural ethos is y'all
can't you can't it's too hard too hard
someone's got to come get you you you
guys have too much pain you just you
can't and and Jade I there's too much
standing in your way I hear I'm
frustrated by that ethos of you can't
because I've I've just had the privilege
for 20s something years sitting with
people who have scratched and clawed and
figured it out and it's amazing to watch
them and I'm frustrated by by those who
say I'm not going to do that I can't do
that I can't I can't drive a Corolla yes
you can yes you can I can't I can't just
go go to work yes you can I just can't
drive in the morning before work and
then deliver pizzas at night I yes you
can there's always something you can do
to better your situation always I don't
care if it's just an inch forward you
keep compiling those inches and before
you know it you will have moved steps
and Bounds and miles further you can and
even if you can't move you can you can
reach out and say will you help me
absolutely will you help me will you
help me and there will be an army of
people there it's just this but you have
to receive the help John right I know
yeah it's it's a culture of
disempowerment that is so heartbreaking
to me um we have that last caller and I
just want to tell her I know you have
this vision for your life and that's
awesome and I actually think you can get
there but you're going to have to stop
saying well I can't do that and I can't
do that and I can't do that yeah because
you're canting yourself into to a
miserable miserable Place yeah and and
the thing is we can all we can all look
at our lives and find reasons why it
won't work right like I could look at
myself I could be like well I I I went
to high school in a small town um I'm
black I'm a female it's harder for women
to get ahead um you know we've got this
debt uh we're just musicians musicians
you know it's feast and famine you know
you're starving artist you can make all
of these assumptions about yourself and
cause them to be true it's almost like
uh it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
like you're in a moment and the moment
sucks like let's be honest like
sometimes you can be in a moment and it
does feel like the walls are closing in
on you but the more you rehearse that in
your brain and continue to say it's true
and have no vision for the future I say
it all the time words matter Berne Brown
says whatever you go looking for you're
sure to find yes yeah she says that I
say it too and I know it came from
somebody okay but it's but it's a
beautiful thing like if I go looking for
opportunity yes we were talking on on
the plane today on the way on the way
back from New York when you said you and
Sam sat down and said if this is going
to actually work we got to start
business we have to yes we got to figure
it out we're going to start a business
then and it's like okay what do we know
how to do we're musicians so let's
figure this out and but it's a matter of
hey Sheila when we're doing it I'm GNA
have to start adjuncting classes and I'm
G to have to become a professor on top
of my Dena students roles and I'm also
going to take this because we got to get
out of this mess and she's like I'm
going to lose you and I was like you're
going to lose me either way at least
this is our path of loss right and you
grind and you grind and you grind and
you grind
then the Sun comes out it does and but
what you said John is really important I
don't think people take enough time to
look forward and dream people don't take
enough time to go they're in the moment
and they see where they're at right now
and it's like H this is just this is me
this is my life this is how it is and
I'm like no let's take a moment and
let's zoom out for a moment in 10 years
and 15 years where would you like to be
taking that time
some taking time to just stare out of a
window and think you know what would it
be like if what would happen if I had
that conversation with my spouse what
would happen if we paid off both of our
vehicles like what would that feel like
taking the time and I challenge anybody
today take some time and dream think
about how your life could be better
write down a couple of ways write and
then write down what must be true
because let me tell you something uh
John with Sam and I you know for anybody
listening for the first time real quick
40 $460,000 of debt coming into our
marriage from student loans and cars and
everything else
and um I knew I wanted not early on did
I know I wanted a family but a little
further in I'm like man I want a family
this is never going to happen you know
like I want to be I had this dream of
like I want to be the type of mom who
can you know go to the field trips and
be there to pick their kid up and you
know I just had this very clear vision
and I was so so so so unbelievably far
from that and it broke my heart and I
remember saying to my husband I'm like I
can't like I can't bring kids into this
M like we've got to clean up this mess
we will be bringing them into such a
mess and there was other things going on
as well too and I remember sitting down
and just being like okay what's got to
be true for anything that we want in
life to happen because this right here
it ain't it and this is not working and
we're so worth more than this and that's
a hard conversation but once you have it
it's like okay there's the North Star
let's start reversing reverse
engineering this thing backwards what's
got to happen first and then honestly
enough people don't sit down with pen
and paper and literally write down what
has to happen A1
first
and if if you don't have a map it's
really hard to what's that what's that
old saying if you don't have a map um
you don't know where you're going You're
sure to you're sure to get there right
you just Meander around yeah if you aim
if you aim at nothing you hit it every
time that's right so yeah I if you hear
us say anything folks who still
listening to this you can you can when
you think you can and it's it's 2 2:
a.m. and you're exhausted and you just
looked at your credit card
balance and you're in bed with somebody
that said I do and yall are so far apart
from each other and your kids don't want
to be around you and you think I'm out
you can and it's a little bitty step and
sometimes it's reaching out and saying I
don't know what to do next will you help
me please go make that call make that
stop and then go get it go get it go do
it look we are normal people all of us
are out here scratching and clawing if
John can do it if I can do it I know it
sounds cliche but you can surely do it
you can tell me you won't do it but do
not ever tell me you can't you can do
this all things are possible this is the
ramsy
show hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the ramsy baby steps
go to ramsy solutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
started